- [Narrator] Should a
flood hit, Japan is ready.
And their solution
is the largest underground
water facility in the world.
(mellow electronic dance music)
About an hour outside of Tokyo
is the Metropolitan Area
Outer Underground Discharge Channel.
This tunnel sits 160 feet underground,
and is around 4 miles in length.
Inside is a network of
large vertical shafts
that store flood waters.
The giant tunnels were built
because this area of Japan
was constantly flooding.
Now, instead of inundating nearby towns,
the water flows underground
and is diverted to a river
that can handle the influx of water,
making sure more than nine
million residents stay dry.
(mellow electronic dance music)
(ding)